this week conflict zone is at NATO
headquarters in Brussels and my guest is
its secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg
facing mounting security challenges the
Alliance is required to project strength
and unity but is struggling on both
counts meanwhile Donald Trump says NATO
is obsolete is he right
again starting back
welcome to conflict zone thank you so
much you keep saying you don't want a
new cold war with Russia and you haven't
got a new cold war but you're getting to
be in the minority there shows all the
signs of being a cold war why don't you
admit it and deal with it because we are
not in a cold war partly because we
don't have the two military bloc's
confronting each other the Warsaw Pact
and and NATO the warship practice and
exist anymore and the Soviet Union
doesn't exist but Russia certainly
exists yes but Russia is upping its arms
China is upping its arms the United
States is upping its arms but Russia is
not the Soviet Union and the Warsaw Pact
doesn't exist anymore at all but we are
in a difficult and challenging security
environment in Europe we are not in the
partnership we try to develop after the
Cold War but are neither in the Cold War
we had before the folder but in war
people have the coalface have a very
different interpretation even yours
your deputy commander of NATO forces in
Europe General Sir Adrian Bradshaw said
last year tensions with Russia could
blow up into all-out conflict posing an
existential threat to our whole being
that's pretty cold war line you've got
the head of German intelligence domestic
intelligence saying the old methods of
the KGB are back you've got the head of
British intelligence mi5 the domestic
service saying increasing threat Russia
poses increasing threat to UK stability
in increasingly aggressive ways that is
a cold war I think we have to be very
specific and very clear about that being
very specific I understand that but but
the thing is that we had to describe the
reality as it is without exaggerating
and talking of tensions and did you seem
to see a different reality no people no
military no I see a more assertive
Russia
I see Russia which has implemented a
substantial buildup and that's exactly
why NATO has implemented the biggest
reinforcements to our collective defense
since the end of the Cold War with
deployment of troops
in the Baltic region and in Poland we
are triple the size of the NATO Response
Force to 40,000 troops and we have
established a high readiness Joint Task
Force exactly as a response to Russia
which has significantly increased its
military presence so you're on high
alert right we have increased the range
are you on high alert we are we have
increased the readiness all forces we
are ready to deploy forces on very short
notice because all the hand we are
signaling that you need to be on high
alert we are increasing threats to the
stability of countries like the UK from
Russia doesn't that require a high alert
that requires a proportionate measured
response from NATO and answer to John
and I played them and that's exactly
what we have delivered by increasing
military presence presence in eastern
part of the Alliance
this is diplomatic speak why no I play
the situation down for me the important
thing is that we react in a measured way
we don't see any imminent threat against
any NATO ally but we see more Russian
presence and we see a Russia which has
been willing to use military force
against neighbors Ukraine and Georgia no
imminent threat and they're talking
about up operated propaganda espionage
subversion and cyberattacks
Russia has designated you a threat to
its national security they did this in
January their new security assessment
they think of you as a threat even if
you don't think of them as a threat
isn't it time you operated your ideas to
coincide with this well we have done a
lot since 2014 where when Russia used
military force against Ukraine and we
have implemented the strongest
reinforcement over collective defense in
Europe since the end of the Cold War so
you bought in the stable door after the
horse about God but this is about
finding the right balance between
providing and military response
providing credible deterrence but also
avoiding escalating the situation and
increasing tensions and the our NATO is
responding exactly in this way because
we convey a message of strength of unity
but also a message that we continue to
strive for a more constructive
relationship with Russia because Russia
is our neighbor Russia is going to stay
there let's talk about deterrence
because you haven't managed to deter
very much these days especially with
Crimea and Ukraine you certainly did
nothing to deter their military action
in Crimea they crashed through an
international border
NATO didn't even see it coming hadn't
the slightest inkling that it was coming
and in April last year the former
Supreme Commander of Allied forces said
there were critical gaps in NATO's
collection and analysis some Russian
military exercises he said caught us by
surprise and our textured feel for
Russia's involvement on the ground in
Ukraine has been quite limited that's a
shocking gap isn't it shocking gap
critical gaps in NATO's collection and
analysis and you say you're projecting
strength you have to understand the
difference between NATO doing its core
tasks which is to protect and defend all
NATO allies and we do that every day
we provide credible deterrence and
that's the exactly reason why we have
seen no attack against any NATO you
supposed to also deter threats to
international peace and stability and
this was a huge threat well the reality
wasn't I'm armed I wasn't doing my work
based on the treaty the Washington
treaty which is the foundation for the
NATO alliance and the obligation of NATO
is to protect and defend all NATO allies
how can you do critical gaps in your
collection and analysis of intelligence
who's responsible for the critical gaps
in NATO's analysis and collection of
intelligence I am I am I am responsible
for what NATO decides and of NATO does
then we have 28 allies providing
capabilities providing forces so we are
an alliance of 28 very effectively don't
even we are the strongest military
alliance in the world we are
strongest military force in the world we
provide the turns okay see Russian
exercises can see and we are doing more
especially when it comes to situational
awareness intelligence that's exactly
why we have invested more in
intelligence why we're developing new
capabilities and also why we now see for
the first time in many years increase
defense spending among European NATO
allies we made a decision in 2014 that
we have to stop the cuts in defense
spending and gradually increase towards
2% you know there were only 5 out of 28
countries that actually pay the 2
percent the encouraging news is that we
have seen that more than 20 allies have
now started to increase defense spending
in real terms the decision we made in
2014 was not to reach 2% next year but
it was to stop the cuts the cuts have
stopped it was a gradual increase we see
a gradual increase in defense spending
and we saw it in 2015 and we saw it in
2016 and that's the first still a long
way from getting to where it needs to
well where you work well well my nature
requires it we have a long way well we
have new allies which have reached 2% we
have Poland we have Estonia and then we
have all the other Baltic countries and
Romania which is now very close to
reaching 3 percent and they were each to
present within a zone I mean in a few
years it may do you don't know where
well what we have seen is is is that
defense spending actually is increasing
and it has done so for two years the
second we have seen very strong
commitments and plants in different NATO
allies to continue to increase but I am
NOT saying that everything is fine I'm
actually traveling around to NATO
capitals and telling them every day to
do more to increase defense spending and
to invest more in our collective defence
you've been powerless to stop or deter
the Russian bombing of Aleppo which has
led to terrible suffering and what the
UN calls war crimes 28 nations in NATO
powerless to prevent this bombing
since all practical
operation has apparently ceased with
Russia you have no levers on which to
persuade them
no levers on which to compel them and
and you sit and watch the bombing of
Aleppo take place with massive civilian
casualties and you can do nothing to
deter it so so much for NATO deterrence
but I think is very dangerous to mix
what is going on in Aleppo and Syria
which is a great concern it's horrific
it's a humanitarian and human tragedy
all the civilians that are killed a with
the courthouse goal NATO to provide the
terrans
for all NATO allies Syria is not a NATO
ally so we should not watch I say water
out the core responsibilities of NATO
defending protecting all NATO I was
watching the Russians dominate a region
in which NATO has key interests yes
which is the eastern Mediterranean when
Russia began the major operations in
Syria it gave the US air force one hour
to get out of the skies that was how
little they thought of them but again I
think we have to so much to tell stand a
difference between NATO's responsibility
which is defend protect all allies and
we are doing that and we provide
credible deterrence every day we have
seen no attack a military attack against
any NATO ally for almost 70 years
then of course NATO is also concerned
about what is going on outside beyond
our borders all NATO allies participate
in the coalition fighting ISIL NATO as
an alliance provide direct support to
the larger lines fighting ISIL with our
Air Act's surveillance planes and we
have started also to Train Iraqi
soldiers and officers because I believe
that in the long run the best way to
project stability is not by deploying
large number of combat troops on the
ground but it is to enable local forces
to fight ISIL themselves and to defend
and protect their own country that's
excluded what you are doing you have
talked about your commitments to later
members particularly under Article five
which means the attack on one country is
seen as an attack on all
of them but it's clear that you can't
meet these commitments because if you
look at the Baltic States for instance
wargames conducted both by the Pentagon
and other groups in Washington have you
losing comprehensively in the face of
any Russian advance on the Baltics you
cannot defend the Baltics and all the
war games that have taken place that
better gonna prove that you can't you
can't meet those commitments we can meet
those commitments we are able to defend
why we lost in all the war games lost
every time they were gained it because
they are lost
no because they are based on the kind of
assumption that we're not able to
reinforce NATO is there with troops we
are we have increased our presence in
the in the eastern part of the lines
with battalions but you don't believe
that battalions are ever to say enough
to protect the Baltic States
we need the national home defence forces
or the Baltic States but perhaps most
importantly we need the ability of NATO
to reinforce if needed we have tripled
us I just don't have that you have a
head of force planning at the Pentagon
saying we just don't have the forces in
Europe NATO is unable to defend them
well well we have already tripled the
size of the NATO space is it be ah we
have 40,000 troops which is three times
as much as we had just a couple of years
ago against 320 thousand but we have a
million people in uniform in the
Alliance so we have development of it so
the new battalions well the battalions
or will their 4,000 troops but 4,000
troops being multinational troops
against 320 but the battalions is one
element of a comprehensive approach the
battalions will be multinational they
will be led by the UK by us by Germany
by Canada and there we and many NATO
allies contributing well a lot of time
and a lot of resistance to doing it well
I think that NATO has been able to react
very rapidly to a changing security
environment you've taken well over a
year to put these battalions we started
almost two years started to increase our
military presence in the eastern part of
the Alliance
actually back in 2014 and now we are
stepping up secretary zero 30 months to
put together four thousand troops
that's a lien but that's not the only
with disagreement from key allies along
the way and you say native values unity
you don't have unity we had a summit in
July where we made all the decisions by
unity this was first mooted in September
last year no we had also went even even
further back you know this I know I've
been rooted for a very long time and
it's taken you a lot of time to put
these four battalions together I know
that we responded immediately after the
illegal annexation of Crimea then
already we started to increase our
presence in the Baltic region with Air
Policing added more exercises then we
have further strengthened our presence
with the four battalions thirty months
today together our achievements but they
they know that we are there to reinforce
if needed and I'm from Norway and the
northern part of Norway has been as is
bordering Russia it was part of the
coldest part of the Cold War we never
had forces in another part of Norway
able to stop the Soviet Union at the
border but we knew that the United
States the United Kingdom the whole NATO
alliance was there to reinforce to
protectors if needed we were even able
to deter an attack on West Berlin no one
thought that it we had the forces in
place in West Berlin during the Cold War
surrounded by East Germany and Soviet
tanks well you keep telling me the world
has moved on then the world is something
but I am Telling You only there's nobody
but who regard you as a threat but even
that we were even able we were able to
even deter the Soviet Union from
attacking northern Norway with hardly
any troops and no no NATO troops at all
there and we were able to deter the
Soviet Union from attacking West Berlin
mr. so of course then by sending a clear
message one for all all for one NATO
solidarity we will be there
to protect the other Terrans all
together for how can you that during the
Cold War I'm certain about that we are
also able to do that with a Russia which
is not as big as the Soviet Union and
the Russia without the Warsaw Pact all
right let's talk about the values of the
NATO alliance ash Carter US defense
secretary said our member nations share
common values reflected in the way we
conduct ourselves really you think you
share common values with Turkey a
country that has just camp down
comprehensively on free speech a whole
history of trumped-up charges against
writers academics and military personnel
wholesale arrest of judges prosecutors
police
anyone who's investigated the government
you share values with this country
Turkey is a key ally for NATO for many
different reasons
no please share values this was my
question you share these values turkey
is member of the NATO alliance and the
Alliance is based on core values and the
human rights but they don't have
democracy at the moment they seem to be
arresting everybody who has a contrary
view to the government Turkish Turkey
experienced a coup attempt and in July
and of course they have the right to
prosecute those reserves about the human
rights in Turkey whatsoever I am I'm
just turning a blind eye I'm telling you
the background for what is going on in
Turkey right but I'm asking you whether
you have concerns about their human
rights record will you turn I have in my
meetings in many NATO capitals also in
Ankara
underline the importance of the core
values for NATO that's the best you can
do in the face of what what is going on
inside I have expressed that I am
personally attached great importance to
those values the rule of law democracy
and individual liberties but they don't
seem to be there and I was but I also
underlined the importance of being able
to prosecute a dose-response
all for the failed queue that they are
prosecuted based on the rule of law and
I also welcome that the Council of
Europe which is the custodians or which
are responsible for the European human
rights convention are in close dialogue
with Turkey and you're not prepared to
give them one word of criticism with you
one word of criticism NATO is shocking
no NATO alliance based system but then
you trumpet the same values you say
we're all having the same values and
when I ask you whether you have the same
values that people who are violating
human rights you avoid the question then
I then I respond to you what I have done
and I have underlined the importance of
these values but I'm also telling you
that Turkey is a key ally because its
location close to Russia the Black Sea
Crimea in the north but also bordering
Iraq Syria in the South now you're
telling me they're too important as an
ally to question just no human rights
values
Turk is important for NATO for many
different reasons part of the
geographical location partly because it
is the ally that has suffered most form
the violence and instability in Iraq and
Syria many terrorist attacks and they
have received 3 million refugees ok all
of this a turkey turkey is not that keen
on NATO these days Turkish Foreign
Minister Chava solo said in September
turkey wanted to cooperate with NATO
members up to this point but the results
we got did not satisfy us therefore it's
natural to look for other options so
this isn't an ally is very pleased with
your alliance at the moment you say
solidarity is a key value for NATO your
solidarity is looking a bit tatty on the
southeastern flank isn't it turkey is
insisting that NATO end its count of
migration operations in the Aegean by
the end of the year you want to continue
with them there are key points of
disagreement that you have major points
of disagreement that you have with
Turkey well NATO is an alliance of 28
independent sovereign nations and there
are very often different views different
opinions
in this is a major split there's nothing
new that there are different opinions
Prince this is not we did not get the
results that satisfy us with NATO that's
directly from that as far as I
remembered that those statements came as
reaction related to what we call NATO
such earnest measures in Turkey
NATO has increased its presence in
Turkey a true mark or two so so that we
Turkey in a very difficult situation
close to Syria and Iraq we have
delivered many of those measures but not
all of them and and I agree with Turkey
that we and I try to encourage NATO
allies to deliver all the agreed
measures so that's one example you have
strong disagreements with Germany as
well the foreign minister Steinmeier
criticized military exercises in Poland
he said they're counterproductive said
NATO should stop saber rattling and war
mongering that's pretty powerful from
the German government but again I think
we have to understand that in alliance
with 28 open democratic societies there
are different views for minister
Steinmeier
i absolutely agree on the need for both
that you've been war mongering and cell
rattling on the need for strong
collective defence in Europe including
exercises and political dialogue with
Russia and again what counts is that
after we have debated off to a open
discussion which I think it's part of a
democratic open alliance he's telling me
also a measure of the RAM at all of us
in in Warsaw and we made the decisions
both on continued efforts to improve our
political dialogue with Russia to avoid
a new Cold War to avoid a new arms race
only agree that Berlin should be
reinforcing these battalions in Eastern
Europe only nine percent and the real
challenge to NATO secretary-general is
the lukewarm support for your
cornerstone principles like article
last year we had the Pew Research Center
reporting significant reluctance among
key countries in the EU to come to the
aid of any NATO country attacked by
Russia at least half of Germans French
and Italians saying their country should
not use military force so this is where
your alliance has got to you cannot
bring the populations of Europe to
actually support your key cornerstone
principles this is a major failure isn't
it again in democratic societies like
Germany and there are different used or
different opinions suppose I bring
public opinion with and I would always
like to have as much support for NATO
policies as possible as possible but
what counts is that we have democratic
elected governments in Germany and all
the other NATO allies which have again
and again committed to our collective
defense to the NATO solidarity an action
in German is a lead country when it
comes to deploying forces to the eastern
part of the Alliance Germany will be a
lead for the battalion in Lithuania they
are lead when it comes to our high
readiness
Joint Task Force the force that can
reinforce if needed and they are playing
a key role for instance when it comes to
more exercises in Europe so what so what
we see on the ground is a willingness of
Germany to be part of this collective
defense and protect all I think what you
see in the United States is one of the
presidential candidates Trump who says
NATO is obsolete and is costing us a
fortune and he's accused Washington's
NATO allies of ripping off the US and
says either they pay up for past
deficiencies or they have to get out and
if it breaks up later it breaks up NATO
this man could be present could be
president-elect in less than a week's
time ah and this is this is a
fundamental challenge to NATO's core
existence that you have to deal with are
absolutely certain that the United
States will understand that also the
future a strong NATO is not only in the
interest of your Syria on the basis of
war but also in the interest of the
United States I will not be part of the
USA
campaign but what I can say is we won't
even stand up for NATO no if you don't
need to interrupt me I'm able to finish
my sentence because I what I can say is
what matters for NATO and that is that
we are defending each other that we our
security guarantees are not conditioned
they are absolute we don't say that we
only protect you if you pay we defend
and protect all eyes without any
conditions but then of course I would
like NATO allies to invest more in
defence and that's exactly what they
have started to do and I welcome that
again starting back thank you very much
for being on conflict sir thank you